yeah hello and welcome to this broadcast
to this live stream I hope it is on it
is um yeah as mentioned not so easy
sometimes to see if I'm really live or
not I hope I am um there is always this
delay yeah so I'm on IC again I really
didn't have time to prepare anything
else it is um a tricky for me today
because I had lots of work and um I'm
just here where I'm always am on the ICC
um there were requests for doing
something on um on chess Cube I will do
that sometime but I will announce it um
before so let's see um I actually want
to do a little bit of um kibitzing
today
and I'm looking for some games to kits
on the thing is I had really I had work
work today all day and I don't really
want to want to play that much
let's see oh the chat box is not in the
video you're totally right that is kind
of weird
um
wait here it
is yep thanks for pointing that out
that's
good yeah it's a bit tricky sometimes
but now it is uh it is back yeah I'm
looking for a game to kiids on maybe I
will play a little bit later but at the
moment I don't feel much like it um if
you if you do like I don't know how much
chest did I do today 5 hours 11 hours
like 13 hours 13 hours on my book then
um no then playing at um 11: in the
evening is a little bit uh a little bit
much but okay maybe a little bit
later
um okay um
check hello from Poland yeah back to PO
all the best back to Poland yeah someone
tells me it's lagging yeah I don't know
I mean the the stream is working and um
maybe you can um can refresh I this is
probably helping it is
um it is sometimes not working for
everybody and um the video stream is
working as see it uh I see it myself in
in my own twitch window but uh it might
need a refreshes
yeah um
okay let's see can I watch something
good here this is a game in three minute
pool so I'm looking for something more
like five minute simply because you can
um comment a little bit
better and there are some good five
minute players on I'm currently looking
through through
them not
much okay then why not
this who is this wgm badir
okay let's uh see yeah you get some some
leg H yeah I don't
um yeah I'm I was working on my book
mostly let's look let's check who bad
girl is anab basa yeah you you maybe
know her yeah she is um one of
those um involved in the feeder
broadcasts she was uh working a lot
during the world championship match one
of the helpers of um of um what's what's
her name
Anastasia Carlovich she's one of her
helpers okay let's see this game here
she's black here in the 5 minute po oh
she's rated 2,000 so not that high
against carero from Spain I've never
play her here bad girl I would have him
remember um yeah I don't
know yeah all the all the best back to
Vienna
thanks um
yeah the lck it's uh I have um I have
some experience with that as well while
watching uh twitch it is really
sometimes just a matter of refreshing a
couple of times and then it's better um
my experience is that it's very little
that I can do really I use the same
stream server all the time which is
basically around the corner and
uh oh now it switches to another game
what is that I have probably have to
unfollow this guy so that we
keep keep being on one game but uh there
is nothing super interesting this is not
that interesting I wanted to know who
badgirl is now I
know uh what about some other games here
yeah I got a request to keep it OAS yeah
he's actually on yeah I can check what
he's doing
oigas um
um uh no challenges at the moment no not
really I don't want to play I don't want
to
play um there's a question
um which defense I would recommend
against E4 that is with good development
and good peace play yeah should be E5
yeah E4 E5 that's U really the one to
recommend
there
the scotch Gambit is not a not a bad
opening it's uh it's equal if black
knows what's going on yeah here o gas is
wide I will kibit a little bit um yeah
can I kibit crazy house on 960 chess
yeah if it is played but they don't play
it that much especially in case of 960
um it's um a little bit of a shame it's
not uh that often played yeah here in
this game here o gas is just a little
bit
better yeah he has got this excellent
Bishop on G2 and Knight on C5 this is
just somewhat nicer for white he's got
this little bit of pressure on the queen
side and um black is um yeah struggling
with an active
plan but
um it's not so easy for white um to get
um something serious going
as
well no I won't I won't play OAS if I if
if I can avoid it it's just it has
absolutely zero entertain entertainment
value because he just trades off
everything and is totally content with a
dead position it's just totally
boring um I don't mind to play a crazy
house game if I get the chance but I
will keep looking at the seek
ads but there is nothing going on in
that resp yeah there is simply no no one
out to to to want to play that it's U
quite uh quite
strange
um there's a question how to donate to
me yeah if you go on my YouTube channel
there is a donation button the channel
page
um my book will be on amazon.com yes but
it will still be a little bit of time
yes
um mysic porn is a mod yes he's helping
out a little bit in case of spammers I
had some spammers in the first two
sessions and it was a little bit
annoying
aning and P missing Pawn was uh nice to
to help me there yeah this is a typical
OAS game yeah he's
just just doing nothing it's totally
equal and he will continue for ages
trying to win on time with 11 extra
seconds on the
clock it's um just the same thing as it
is all the
time um
yeah maybe is white a little bit better
probably not with the A2 Pawn Yeah black
is uh always tying the white king this
is a very typical um Rook end
game where the white King has problems
to activate yeah he can never go on the
third rank because of Rook G3 check
white can try to invade to E5 but um it
is um yeah now we get three against
three and if you think that they would
agree to a draw n n
Mr OAS has got 20 extra seconds and he
will continue that till the end of
days um okay um is there some more
question yeah I will be reviewing uh
games of my channel viewers that can be
sent to me um it is something that I
will um announce with a separate
video I think it's a good idea to review
some amateur games and uh I really want
to give u channel viewers the chance to
send in their games um would you do a
complete repertoire for your students in
PGN and or video yeah of course I mean
this students that work with me um in my
in my lessons we will um of course also
talk about openings and complete a
repertoire that like sorry complete a
repertoire like that um
um yeah this is a typical oigas game
white never had anything really he just
shuffles around does nothing let's see
what happens here he now offers a rook
trade will they agree to a draw he's got
4 seconds extra on the
clock I don't
know
um we can we can play but I really don't
like at the moment I had really had a
hard day
yeah um and um yeah I do read chess
magazines mostly in un chess that's
that's really
nice yeah they continue but black
actually has a couple of extra seconds
so maybe uh black can win on time giving
him a taste of his own
medson yeah this is the kind of stuff oh
Rook no sorry this is the kind of stuff
he does all day shuffling around in this
kind of uh end
games King G5 maybe white has some
chances now I don't know why black um
ever um yeah moved his uh his King out
this was really not necessary at
all
yeah that's tricky now for black that
was a very bad way to play getting the
king to
C5
um I yeah Rapport is playing stuff like
Knight A3 in the cilian quite
often it's it's funny it's not that bad
um
yeah there's a question about the black
repertoire against E5 yeah maybe maybe
send me a mail for
that
um I do follow V yes that's a very
talented player o guess is winning this
game it's kind of
a
uh yeah kind of weird because it was
never everything
happening yeah he lost but why on Earth
did he did he go with his King out I
mean here black is completely safe and
he went to B4 this is this is really uh
completely
unnecessary okay we got something
interesting going I will start to follow
morovich and I hope he will play some
some games
um
um do you think you would beat morphe if
he came back and didn't learn any Theory
um he didn't this the this these are
very theoretical
things he was exceptionally strong for
his time that's clear but he also had
his bad
games it's
um those kind of things are are tough to
say yeah crazy house you know it's not
like I can in just pull a game out of my
head there are simply no players who
want to play that I'm checking the seek
graph here there's a seek graph you know
and there is no crazy house
on it's not
uh it's not that easy to get a game with
that it seems
um I wonder why isn't he playing Maru
I'm following morovich hoping that he
will start a game but uh he's playing
right right um uh quite often at the
moment so I hope that um there will be
some games
coming
um yeah more twitch streams with
subscribe option um yeah I'm I'm not
um the thing is I cannot offer a
subscription option on Twitch you need
to be a twitch
partner and um
I I've I've checked that um I don't I'm
not really eligible if this is a word
for twitch um partnership it seems I I
did apply but um they didn't answer yet
so um yeah I'm not not sure what happens
there but um we will we will
see um a blindfold game I never
considered that
yeah Morrow is not playing I keep an eye
I keep an eye but uh as long as he's not
starting a game let's see if we can do
something else oh here here we are let
me switch it a little bit so that this
is fine yeah this is uh morovich playing
here on the black
side I'm playing light like that's a
German I am Martin suum Zander about my
my um my
strength um do you play this schan
Gambit um
sometimes I will cover T Steel 2015 yes
maybe not all
rounds um maybe not all rounds because
I'm on a
holiday for a week during the tournament
tournament
um
the difference between a GM and IM is um
in terms of uh
requirements is um is just that for both
you need three exceptional results
basically um which are called title
norms and for Norms you need to um have
a certain rating performance and um the
rating performance for for GM Norms is
just much higher
for um for IM Norms it is um it is 2,450
and for GM Norms 2,600 so it's much more
difficult to do and you need a higher
base rating of 2,500 for GM instead of
2,400 for Im so it's much more difficult
it is from the type of requirements it's
the same it's just much more difficult
I find it funny that someone called ban
ladage is is spamming the channel I mean
Bon Lage actually attended the
tournament that I played on Mya in in
May and it was quite funny to observe
him because he he wore the same clothes
all
day uh for one week yeah he never
changed um I mean with that kind of
attitude I don't know
difficult
um oh I'm sorry I I hit I hit myself at
the desk um okay
um yeah chest will probably not be
solved in
um anytime soon it is just uh too much
to
calculate but
um maybe in I don't know couple of
hundred years I'm not I'm not not an
expert on that but
um let's see what about this game here
actually um mosovich is black yeah we
have equo material and it's a very
protected prot W protracted situation in
the center Knight F4 looks interesting
but why didn't play that he's going for
Knight F4 here for Knight E6 which looks
dangerous yeah black is covering the E6
Square so that Knight E6 is not hitting
that
hard and um yeah he's got 30 seconds
more on the clock this is a 3-0
game
difficult
um I don't know with medium quality and
HD I streamed in
HD so no difference really all four
streams are technically
identical I got a comment that I love
black shirts that's
true I mostly have uh black
shirts um the the reason is that um I I
was working what what is happening here
black has an extra porn yeah I was
working in this um in this um in this
bank for uh 17 years and um it is uh it
was pretty normal that people were uh
shirts and ties and business uh business
uh clothing and I never really liked
that so I decided to to just stick with
black which is uh kind of a middle of
the road thing it's not U typical
business stuff but at least uh it it it
kind of um yeah it's not very uh
offensive yeah like haai shirts would be
a little bit a little bit
strong
um um yeah I'm a YouTube Partner
but this is nothing special
really yeah here white has just
blundered a piece under huge time
pressure it um will be uh would have
been difficult anyway to uh to hold this
end game black had the bishop here and
an extra pawn it was a little bit much
so we will probably see more games foror
I hope it's always entertaining to watch
him
um yeah solving chess I think
mathematically is very very difficult um
I think they will
um they will um get closer in some
aspects especially uh table bases yeah
like seven men eight men table bases
this is in fact um I don't know if I
like it but you huge um
progress um if they would get to eight
eight main table bases solve completely
is it's quite amazing um yeah I actually
enjoyed my job there but um well it's
it's something nice to do a your hobby
as a as a job of course it's always
nicer than doing something else I guess
but it's it was um basically enjoyable
yes
um
I've played wolf Anderson in Blitz yeah
but never in
person yeah I enjoy that larger
audiences watch my uh my videos sure it
uh it is just more fun to produce for
for more
people um yeah he's not playing here
yeah Morrow I keep observe on but until
that happens I'm looking at a game here
cowch s
against lunatic X croan is davorin
kovich Croatian Grand
Master ah oh wow wow wow yeah that's oh
okay now we have a better game this this
is this is very
interesting um we have iGo gerv Mor
morovich playing Dirty Sexy Money yeah
Dirty Sexy Money is um kind of a yeah is
is a is a mystery player yeah
he's got black resigns oh black resigns
so Morrow has a problem playing him okay
maybe you think that this guy is a
cheater it's got a picture in there H
okay I actually played him once and won
I cannot remember
that H he's got super high ratings super
high
ratings
H
mysterious he's got over
2,600 here H
amazing very
tough okay but he does not who do we and
now we get Morrow playing FM mighty king
yeah mighty
king oh wow this is um this is um a
British feedom master and if I'm not
mistaken his name is is Hayden Daniel
Hayden Daniel I played him in my chess
Cube days
interesting
um um there will be twitch streams um
yes um after Christmas or let's say in
the in the new year um I will definitely
uh continue to do the um
um to do the ICC streams that that's
clear and I will also do streams on my
own but Ian feel not like a daily thing
or anything it simply eats too much time
it's um it's nothing that I can do on a
daily
basis okay let's have a look a little
bit at this game people said in the in
the comments to the streams I should do
a little bit
more um yeah about Chess than talking
yeah this and that I think uh it's um
something that um is in a way through I
should look at the games a little bit
more here I think Morrow is just clearly
better this looks like um very very
problematic um French defense white will
get a bishop to F6 a knight to
G5 oo this doesn't look
good
[Music]
yeah the the dark squares are a big
problem Oh Black just blundered his
night
oo oh he continues that's fun I think I
would resign against Morrow if I'm a
whole piece
down and a position
basically oh wow
um yeah white is just totally winning
there's a question about um
Carson has he lost some of his form he
hasn't been that persuasive lately
lately um a user game review won't cost
anything I will just uh have people send
the games to me and I will do that on
the channel there's no no cost um
involved um
I don't think that Carson has has lost
lost much of his his form actually or
something he was certainly um um yeah um
busy with preparing for the world
championship match and it wasn't even so
clear if and when it would happen the
kind of uh the problems with the the SOI
venue and so on res so I don't know I
think it's good that the next World
Championship Match is in two years and
he has some time to actually play play
tournaments and maybe work on his game a
little bit and uh I think um there is no
reason to believe that he um that he has
some I don't know um declined in
strength or or something like that I
really don't think so so I'll keep
following um morovich here but he's not
playing that uh
quickly so I mean I mean in quick
succession now this kind of uh game
yeah it's difficult there resigns there
are many many
question I don't know card's handle on
ICC yeah and I have no special
suspicion
there is a question what is a good book
for 1800 player who is more positional
H um I will I will post a video about
this um this subject of sending games to
me for revie it will be something uh
will probably set up a mail address for
that have you ever been so irritated for
losing a game that you didn't want to
analyze with your opponent um
um I'm not quite
sure probably yes but I don't remember
something
special it's
um it's a good idea to um analyze at
least a little bit without the computer
and only then use the
computer this uh this makes some sense
to make up your mind at first on your
own and only then um use the computer to
confirm what you were
thinking yeah I've switched to a game
here with yosik being black he's a GM
from the US and he has no name in and
croan is this creation
GM we have um a Kings India here where
black has blasted open this now we
switch tomorrow he's always just
starting a game when the other game is
sort of on let me tidy up the screen
here a little bit it's not so easy to
watch here playing Coba don't know that
guy we have a Scandinavian
defense um I use a um a Blue Yeti
microphone it is a a really big ass
microphone
have I ever played a serious game
against someone you suspected of
cheating in real life
no yeah you can lose weight during a
tournament I'm pretty
sure um what is this here this looks
very very uh funny white is threatening
Bishop takes G4 winning a piece and I
don't see what black should do black
resigns
um it's not so tough to get
self-employed in Germany taxes and
regulation I feared it would be more
difficult so it is um it is quite
okay ah now someone CAU Lis GGO is on
and asking sex questions that's
funny
okay we have a GM here Freddy Krueger
with white no name in
there against Morrow yeah and Morrow is
sacrificing an exchange on E3 that's
funny yeah he gives up an exchange to
get good dark Square control yeah black
now has excellent play on E5 this is not
an not a sacrifice that that um is
probably entirely correct in um in a
longterm in a long time control game but
in a Blitz game you can certainly do
it Knight H5 Knight G3 these kind of
ideas Bishop on A6 looks kind of
funny Knight F3 against the Scandinavian
is is quite good
I don't think that the Grand Prix
assilian is dubious for white it should
U
probably be equal I don't think black
can get an
advantage if white plays with Bishop B5
at least Bishop C4 is I don't
know not so great I
think yeah Wesley so is an interesting
player for the for the the world title
definitely yeah here black black has got
an excellent Bishop on E5 but still the
thing is that in this kind of structure
the bishop on C8 is doing uh doing
nothing yeah the C8 Bishop is just a
very silly piece and you never know what
to do with this piece you cannot trade
it somewhere and while black is sort of
solid it's it's difficult to find a way
forward for
him
uh I got a question about uh chess
Network yeah I think it's content is is
totally okay for the target audience
it's uh it's really okay and he's not
bad in Blitz as well I mean there was a
there was someone saying that he's only
um um only good in bullet he actually um
had at times a very high five minute
rating on the
IC but um he never publicly um yeah he
never uploaded any videos uh with this
account or anything we played a couple
of games and uh but he never wanted to
have any any public match let's
say the title players on ICC play for
free
did ever lose against a significantly
lower rated player yeah definitely
definitely but not often I mean one one
thing that uh I think is quite um yeah
what is good about my Chas is I rarely
lose
against much lower rated players I mean
I have never lost them against the 20
below 2,000 player for ages it's really
ages ages
uh um ago I mean I cannot remember
actually the last
time I haven't lost the white game
against the non GM for seven years
now so I never I don't lose that
much um no I don't think kolana lost um
because of Any media
pressure it just he he had an
exceptionally great run in the singfield
cup and and and around that but um it is
just you cannot play on 3,000 level uh
all the time it's it's simply not so
easy I know a couple of players from
Aran yes play with them in my Belgium
and a Dutch team
white
resigns um the highest rating achievable
for someone who starts Chess at age 20
not so
easy not so
easy if you work real hard you can
certainly become like 2,000 or more
maybe more but it's difficult this is
something that's not happening very
often but um can be can be TR
certainly going over 2,000 I don't know
if there are
um if there are um um examples for that
but there are late starters who became
really strong I mean I think that Max
over the world champion started really
late okay we have um another moral game
here the alin's defense and he plays
with F4 that's
fun just the the big four pawn
attack this is kind of waving um this
this red flag at a bull yeah and Morrow
certainly wants to
attack he pushing everything forward
yeah now black will play D5 I guess
trying to grab on E5 he doesn't H I
think I would have taken the
pawn
I think I would have taken the pawn to
get to have at least something here H4
H5 I don't
know there's a Swedish GM who started
playing chess when he was 17 interesting
I don't know who that is I would be
interested to
learn
yeah black just blundered here and is
totally wiped out where's the Knight on
B6 going that looks uh looks
funny Queen B6 Rook C8 but white can
just take on
D6 that looks that looks quite strong
for black for white I mean anti anti
resigned the GM here yeah the alak
kind's defense is a slightly risky
opening and if you make one or two
mistakes it will uh get to you quite
quite
quickly um yeah I think studying is a
big part of improvement in chess there
is uh of course talent but um you should
um study quite a quite a
lot yeah the Dual commentary with u
against Jean bori was very interesting
uh I was very lucky in the first game
and um won the second game which was
nice the nice um the the second game was
very
nice yeah I I can challenge morovich but
he won't accept simply because uh my
rating in the normal Blitz is so low I
don't get any people playing against
me I would need to really uh yeah try to
get this uh this um rating up to have
any chances at OPP positions but at a
good
opposition is there no there's someone I
can put out a seek for this crazy house
stuff I can try but uh I have my doubts
that someone takes me
on yeah unfortunately I only speak uh
English and German and I don't play any
instrument absolutely
nothing yeah actually I'm thinking about
playing a couple of games I have to
admit that it feels kind of weird not to
play a little bit at
least got another moral game incoming
challenge ah um okay game started okay I
I got a game in crazy house so you will
see now what crazy house is um I'm I'm
going to start with D4 and I will I will
show you the general concept just just
put something
something on the board and uh then we'll
see the point is that whenever a piece
gets
taken then you get the opportunity to
put that piece in on the board instead
of making a move so a difference is that
you see like here I'm I'm capturing the
the N now and see that I have a knight
here with a one so I can now put in this
Knight in instead of a move if I want um
and he can put in this bishop yeah so we
will you we will
see how this works
out
yeah like
here let's see if I'm I I'd like to get
take some Knights because Knights are
notoriously tricky in all kinds of buck
house and and stuff like that he's got
two Bishops at the moment that he can
that he can
um can uh play how would you tell that
yeah he can um put on the board let's
say but Bishops the position is not very
open I'd like to open up the position to
actually show how it works at the moment
I don't have anything good where I could
put a knight
yeah I really don't see where I could
put a knight where it just is helping me
a
lot
um maybe H3 here it's kind of weird this
is 31 by the way so 1 second
increment I think uh all squares are
legal for
placing uh placing pieces I think pawns
up to the seventh rank also is check all
this is legal the guy is not
playing okay I have to take yeah and he
takes here as well so I have two Bishops
and two knights to to use and now it
gets interesting um he could for example
play Knight G5 he's not using his option
A here now you see he put put a knight
on D2 and he forked me yeah rook and
queen were forked if I go to G3 now um
he would play um Knight E2 yeah and and
for my queen again on the king this time
so very problematic I try to to play
this okay so can I do something with my
Knights my Bishops and
stuff let's see I can take on G7
uh okay he can probably play Then Rook
G8 he just has taken a rook
so I wonder Rook
G8 is there anything nice that I can do
here Knight on C5 maybe let's let's put
something on C5 that's
funny yeah KN F5 was also
interesting yeah what I'm threatening is
Bishop
F7 with
check yeah I have two Bishops that I can
put on the board and one Knight of
course he has stuff as well so he can
consider Bishop H2 check King takes F1
and so yeah I will take that that much
is
clear yeah and now I can take G7 or I
can put something on F7 but this is just
a check unfortunately I cannot check him
with a
knight I can play Bishop H5
though yeah give this
check I never bet on
chess
yeah and this is tricky now whatever he
will put in in the way of the bishop I
will take and it's it's difficult now
the initiative is is worth a lot here I
think he could have played Bishop to H2
check this would have been interesting
yeah now I will
take and again time warning put this
this on the
board difficult
now
yeah now I can play Bishop F7
check King H7 that's Queen G6
mate oh is here inom challenge this is a
cute mate
right this is crazy house for
you okay this is how this game is played
it's uh quite quite
funny yeah maybe I can uh try again
let me put out another another crazy
house challenge this is
funny two light squared Bishops I think
uh what he could have done is probably
should have done he he could have put
something on H2 with check Bishop H2
check and this would have been very
problematic I was probably a loss there
it's not a very high rated opponent but
you don't get opponents here at all
I think there's there's not even comps
offering
it incoming
challenge game started here we go Louis
Silva let's let's do
this crazy house for
you okay yeah H this is kind of E4 is
more more fun in crazy house just
opening up the position
quickly let's see this is five minute
now I will I will try to get get a
knight
quickly try to take the Knight yep I
always like knights in crazy
[Music]
house I have a knight that I can use but
I don't know where really Knight C4 for
fun come on let's put a knight on
C4 it's a bit early actually but it
looks like fun he can play B3 though B3
is bit of
annoying huh is there any way I thought
B3 Knight B2 but this is kind of weird
probably U not a good
idea
okay let's attack here E5 if he takes
D4 you have to be really cautious with
sacrificing yeah in in Crazy house it's
basically a double sacrifice yeah you
you sacrifice on the board and
everything he takes he gets in his hand
as well so it's uh very tricky that
way okay I wanted to give the check here
anyway
okay he put Pawn on C3 yeah to block the
check I will take
him check okay so I've got this in
play now I'm threatening Queen D1 M and
I think yeah this is I'm not sure if
this possible it is Queen D1 mate this
is the problem I have a queen trade yeah
I could put in a queen on D1 to to
checkmate
ah incoming challenge
okay game started now now I'm going to
play
E4 um my some passions other than chess
I think nothing is really comparable uh
to that but um I really like movies and
uh some TV series this kind of thing is
is I um I watched lots of movies at this
uh
something that clearly stands
out okay let's see Knight C3 yeah for
big
development yeah D5 let let's push I
have a I have a pawn that I can that I
can uh use I will put it on on here so
that um F7 can be
a can be uh taken or if he takes I go
Knight
E5 Bishop B5 is also
interesting now this is this is even
more interesting King F7 takes on E6 is
really
ugly yeah the rating is uh is is really
crazy at the moment because is the the
the the first game sim okay I'm taking
here have to be cautious with the queen
trade or wait is there something else no
I will take
him
check I did not watch the
interview and I didn't watch The Hobbit
movies I wasn't so interested really I
must be must be honest there I watched
Lord of the Rings of course and it was
great but I didn't watch The Hobbit
movies
check yeah he he's using his pawns there
and I will take them he only has a pawn
left now so at the moment he has an
extra Queen on the board but I have a
queen and two
pawns that I can that I can use so now
let's have a look here I can do this
here I can take him first this is nice
and now Pawn to
F7 yeah if he takes with the King Knight
E5 will will
win so he probably moves King to d8
right yeah and
now I can do
this
yeah and if he takes I can think of how
to continue if I take I could I could
actually get a
knight but I don't see a
Checkmate it looks like they should be
one oh Knight King to
D7 check um where is it wait I have
to I have to get get a knight
here check under promotion this is just
just better yeah with with the Knight
how to do that it looks like I mean I'm
seeing a mate but I I sort of want to do
it with a
knight yeah okay come
on this is a this is a win
it's nice yeah it's
nice it looks nice
right okay yeah I like Skyrim better
than Oblivion yeah it's just a a bit
more a bit bit more complete game just
better in in every every
aspect um here I have a crazy house guy
with he wants to
play wants to play Let's see I'm going
with E5 which is
a the most open way to
play uh okay the fried liver would be
fun I have played about 400 hours in
Skyrim a little bit more
maybe
I have played a pen paper and dice table
RPG in my youth yes
H I didn't see the interview this movie
no yeah I'm losing points but okay this
is the the weird rating pool here for
crazy house Knight G5 yeah he wants to
take on F7 but I don't know how good
this
is yeah he can take on F7
but he can take on
F7 Knight and Bishop I I rather have
Knight and Bishop here than a
rook that's a question what Kristal
wultz if I like him yeah excellent actor
right he was excellent in both um in
glorious bastards and and also in um in
the other one in um now come on Jungle
Unchained okay so I'm going to try to
attack him now we have not yet taken
anything yeah so there's nothing to put
on the board
so I cannot set I wanted to do something
to E2 or so but it's not so
easy I cannot he never there's nothing
that was ever taken in this game okay
I'm going to provoke that now that he
has
to uh has to move the Knight back or
take on
F7 okay so we will have this
trade ah yeah this is cute right this
kind kind of pin but I can actually do
something on my own
here yeah I will get his
Queen oh interesting so
he's just not allowing
me a check on F3
H I have nothing to put on put on the
board now um but he will take
here
H
interesting yeah okay I will I will take
him it will be very problematic him I
this Pawn on F7 is very very dangerous
check
yeah okay at least here I don't have
much
Choice Rook H7 would be Checkmate but
there's still the Knight on
F6 he just has taken this so far he has
a rook and a knight now but
both it's not it's not huge threat going
on now I will try to threaten Bishop
takes G2
check
Bishop takes G2 check for Queen F3 but
he's got rook and Knight to defend so
not easy at
all maybe I should have played Queen D7
or something like
that I'm not
sure if he takes I would just take with
the Knight threatening G2 Pawn to G2
funny I will play um after this here I
will play a couple of normal games it's
kind of weird to not have a normal game
in so I'm going to take here so that I
have a pawn that I can actually put on
G2 but the thing is he can maybe maybe
he will defend here with putting
something on G2 himself The Rook hangs
but that's maybe not so
important
I'm threatening Pawn to G2 now King G2
Knight H4 check and then Queen to
G2 yeah Pawn to G2 is a huge
threat King G2 Knight H4 check King
moves and queen G2
check yeah he cannot play a slow move
like Knight
D5 I think because of the the G2
threat okay put a knight on the8 so I
will do that
now check
check and
check wait not so quick
check my book is an is an opening
repertoire book on the nimzo and boo
Indian will be released in March
April
so let's see I can take on F2 and I
actually get a
pawn
check I get a
pawn this is good can sacrifice Here and
Now check
here check for Rook F2 yeah Rook F2 will
be very
cute
Checkmate that's crazy
our Maiden one I did have a maiden
one I don't
know Queen H2 where was the maiden
one
I don't know I I don't
know I don't know I didn't see it I
didn't see
it one one more game here maybe
rematch game started let's let's do
this
one more crazy house game and then I'll
play some some normal
games that someone asking me if I was
the funny guy in my class at
school um I don't
know sometimes yeah maybe
sometimes okay let's see if I can get
something going here like
E5 E5 quickly looks interesting
I can go E5 no Knight F3 maybe and then
E5 yeah I'm playing the nimso Indian
zish variation quite a lot that's
true my book will show how to how to
play against it of course it's a black
repertoire
book
okay so I have a pawn that I could put
on
F6 maybe I can do that it will probably
win a piece because he has to
sacrifice and I could play Maybe here
yeah to to pin the
Knight he has got two pawns though two
pawns is always good pawns are very
tricky
here
threatening to take here I will
take and now I have a knight that I
could put in but okay first winning
here D5 yeah I can just take that
actually the question is how with the
bishop maybe for Bishop takes
A6
there is a question have you ever won
money playing chess yeah I
did I won an open tournament last year
in
Austria first price and this was I mean
people can look it up so it's no big
secet this was
1,000 but that was by far the biggest
priz I ever got in the Jess it was a
very nice uh very nice
experience Okay so what to do now I
could put something on E7 right a Pawn
on E7 looks kind of
problematic it looks very strong and
I've won a queen so whenever I got
nearest King will be very very
tricky C3 oh see oh yeah that was cute
yeah Bishop before before I just
blundered this Pawn that was nicely
played I didn't see that at
all h
wow okay maybe I should just secure this
[Music]
bishop what does he have a rook and two
pawns
okay can I go to D2 or is this not a a
good Square I guess it's
okay now the pieces that are set in are
the ones that I take so if I take a pawn
I can use this Pawn to put on the
board yeah so I have got a queen that I
could put in because I want it earlier
and he's got the Rook that I used to
take the queen on
d8 yeah he put something on F3 yeah I
can take but he could put something on
G2 then so like Pawn to G2 is a
possibility
now see that is interesting right what
now H I cannot
Castle he's only got a rook that he can
put on the board but like Rook G1 yeah I
have to do that
right Rook G1 he can put Rook on H2
hm that's not so good
right I don't see a good move
here that's really unlucky this kind of
situation Rook G1 Rook on H1 how do I
defend that
never let him take
my
Rook
yeah I have no move here I have no
move this is not good yeah but what else
tricky really
problematic and he can put he has two
Rooks now yeah I can put Rook on
G1 and uh he got enormous counterplay
here he's got no Queen to put on G1 but
a rook he
can
yeah this is not easy not easy at
all I don't know what to do here can put
another Rook on G1 I have no attack here
his two Bishops are super great in
defending I have two
knights
maybe just
defense I have no new years's resolution
really
no
check he just took
it yeah if I take he can put a knight on
G2 with check H he's got a huge
initiative my pieces are not worth very
much yet time warning quite
amazingly Knight G1 Sheck Rook King to
D2 where this kind of stuff I have no
attack here that's a big problem and
he's got all the attack going I can't
even I have a queen that I could put on
the board
but I have no there is nothing to attack
I need to get near his King
somehow I don't know how
though
yeah let's just play a defensive move
sometimes it's an idea to just let the
opponent put in some pieces and that
he's not that he's got nothing in hand
you know and then you just continue to
play and you have stuff in reserve I
have huge stuff in reserve that I cannot
use at the
moment
Checkmate yes yes yes yes
great yes yet this
[Laughter]
one wow wow wow
wow
ah
uh oh okay I let's let's do one
more H that was
cool um my longest game of chess um
started in terms of moves um I had one
that was far above 100 moves um I don't
have it anymore it was in the Dutch
league and I was actually uh playing
against the feedom master and uh this
guy didn't know how to mate
with with bishop and uh and
Knight against the blank King and I
continued to play with the blank King
and he he did manage on move
48 uh I don't have the score sheet of
that
anymore it uh I mean it's not in the
database it was an awfully long game of
course so um I really want revenge here
you know
but um not easy I I will I try to open
up the position early
here it's maybe
risky maybe
risky yeah he's got a knight and a pawn
always tricky Pawn to H6 if I take
Knight F6 this kind of stuff I have a
bishop and
a pawn which is not that good in
comparison I think at least I don't I
would I would like to have the Knight
here all the
time yeah yeah yeah I saw that but what
what could I do against it not
really G6 is Knight coming to
G7 I can take and let him put the Knight
on
G7 not great but check it's just one
night yes at the
moment I recommend the the main line
against the
zish it's not too much of a spoiler you
still have to know what the main line
is okay he wants to put it on F5
yes okay I put this
here to cover F5 and if he takes I will
actually get a knight and I like that D3
is also hanging
check yeah this is this is safe now and
G2 hangs so I have two pawns that I can
put on the
board and a knight so let's
see can I do something
here I have to move the queen first I
guess yeah to D6
he has put the bishop on e4 so he has
everything in play now he has got
nothing that he could put in and um I
have a knight and two pawns so I
actually have some
Firepower and he doesn't so I will take
now
here for Knight G4
yes yeah come on
check not going to think about that very
long and I can actually also if he takes
with the King Pawn G3 is also
interesting um I go Knight G4 he can
maybe just take
it this is also interesting let's put
this
in trying to drag the king farther
further
out Pawn takes I have ideas to take the
Rook as
well whenever he has a rook in hand or a
queen there's there's something on E8
yeah the minimum rating for my book
maybe 1,800 or something like that maybe
1,700 around that around that
range
I actually think that if you are rated
lower than that opening books don't make
that much sense at all You' got other
things to to uh to learn let's
say okay yeah I can put a knight on uh
Pawn on G3 again maybe do
that just opening up the position
more and I keep getting stuff back in
the process
so
he takes with the pawn I can I can take
on H1 probably will do
that I don't know that three check V
variant
really I think this is the one where
three checks win yes but I I don't know
that never played
it
yeah I can put another Pawn here
on on uh on F4 but I wonder I will I
will actually take here
first as mentioned he has got nothing
that he has a bishop and two three pawns
but they bishop and pawns don't really
help him here
so I just got this Rook now and I can
continue
here this will be difficult
Knight on G4
Y and I have a rook
coming he's got a rook bishop and three
pawns the question is I have a rook to
to put in but where where
exactly it's not so great
[Music]
actually I can win the queen yeah but he
has Rook E8 at the
end and it's not that great actually I
just have a rook and it doesn't help
much
I can I can play Rook D1 check on D1
with the Rook King takes Knight F2 check
takes on H1 but he's got rookie a
check
yeah maybe he can win with rookie eight
I don't
know our Bishop f8 is strong
actually
okay
difficult my idea is that Rook e 2 is
threatened but um I think it was very
problematic anyway he can play this
check now ah this is strong yeah Bishop
f8 check King takes Rook E8 check King
G7 Queen h8 Checkmate that's a funny
line so on Bishop f8 check I I have to
go to D7 or check okay here at least I
only have a move only have one
move yeah does he have a win now
maybe takes with the
pawn now he took so it is actually my
move and I have rook and pawn so I can
put this this Pawn in and I got the
initiative now that's that's the most
important
thing
probably probably for a
win oh wow I have do I have no check now
what is he threatening something he has
a knight time War Knight C five I can
still
take I can take
C1 so that I have a bishop again that's
very
important
so no checks
anymore give a check here
yeah but it's uh it's not helping me
very
much check
and now I can take here check I don't
know if it helps
but at least I have I have a pawn that I
can that I can place on the
board I have to play buddy only six
seconds
left
wow
wow is can he made me Rook d8 is checkm
yeah Rook
d8 this is just a check with no big
Point behind it I don't see how I
prevent Rook d8
Rook d8 Bishop D7 there must be a
Checkmate
somewhere
check
check black forfeit on
time yeah I'm also M it yeah King D7 he
can put a rook here for
mate oh wow this is great crazy this is
really
crazy
[Laughter]
wow okay I need I need to drink some
water oh
wow that was crazy
stuff okay so this
is about 38 minutes left I'm going to
play some normal games yeah just some
normal
games uh so that uh or do we do we want
to rematch here I don't know let's do a
rematch this was
funny game started okay this guy is uh
dangerous
here let's see can I can I get a win in
here
maybe the
advance the short variation
this is like a normal game here why not
just just try to play
normally let's just play normal stuff
here this is still crazy house yeah we
just playing a normal
opening okay so he's pushing pawns I
just I just continue here normal normal
game and see what happens I don't have
to react to that I can go Bishop G5
maybe bishop E7 yeah this is good yeah
Bishop E7 I will
take Bishop E7 I will
take and then put put put it on D6 again
the
bishop
um let's take
it the thing is he has got we both have
a bishop now but I think my Bishop
coming to D6 is the
much more annoying piece let's
say black forfeits due to disconnection
oops oops Yeah he he disconnected and
forfeited oh
okay um he said he he was wait
he said he was watching the
stream so um it is not uh
something
um not something that he wanted let me
check can
I is he still is he on again let's
check yeah he
reconnected maybe we can get another
game yeah it happens yeah it happens
no I never played the Lan Gambit it's
just bad it's really just
bad yeah I'd like to get if I get one
win
in we have an equal score here then I
can play um some normal games w Really
the French
Exchange
yeah my experience in crazy house is
really very
limited I um have played this maybe a
dozen times or
so I want to want to get Knights I mean
I have some experience from when I was
much younger with uh with buck
house which is a bit similar but not
quite the
same yeah you can have four Bishops on
the same
color I play the schan Gambit
yes sometimes at
least trying to get his
Knights is he disconnected
no okay let's just
Castle I have a knight and the pawn but
at the moment no great ideas to put them
in he has bishop and pawn so he can put
something in the way of The
Rook let's
see to
E2 nothing left for him to put in
now can take here for yet another Knight
that's not so
bad
[Music]
um I could put a Pawn on B2 but that's
not helping so
much
not so easy he's got he's got a ton of
Bishops something
here I'm not vegetarian
no I think it's good if you are really
but um it's
it's something I I cannot do really at
the moment with my diet I mean maybe I
could but it's it's It's Tricky I I
don't see
how um okay he's got a bishop and a pawn
so I'm going to take with
this to
E5
yeah
yeah that's looks it looks tricky
here let's see if he takes with the
bishop I can play Knight
D5 and otherwise I can take on F2 yeah
for some
attack so Bishop
here
with a check here King takes there
Knight E4
check he's got pawn and Bishop H he's
got no Knight and no Rook to put in
that's very
good I'm thinking about it I think he
has to play King one yeah I wonder if
Knight E4 is a move for Knight
G3 giving up giving up the
queen maybe this for Knight
D5 there is no chess Cafe where I live
no it's not very
um very common nowadays to have this
this kind of thing
unfortunately it's
nice yeah I hope I get some attack going
here if he moves this bishop I will put
a knight on E3 and win the queen this
was the
idea also trying to lift this
pin okay okay this this looks
funny I have two knights yeah that I can
put in so let's start with
that and here the good thing is oh he
now we can put a knight on F6 for a
check but he he had no piece to put in
with a check that was very
nice and now I can put another Knight in
on F2 uh on D2 actually
is this good or on
E3 yeah put it on
E3 um but I don't see yet how this helps
me so
much uh King King F2 I have Bishop to H4
yeah yeah that is good and here maybe
Pawn to F2 or something he's threatening
Queen G7 made so I have to have to be
quick
here or should I do something defensive
here yeah like Knight
here it's maybe not that bad for
something on E3
yeah Bishop E3
check
huh yeah well Knight F6 I can take
that's
good and he's he's got no the the
Bishops are useless here there's no
check here okay he took
there if I take on can I take the queen
now let's check that he can give I can
take the queen come on check oh this
check I didn't think about that okay I
have to take check and another check
coming so I probably have to take
twice it's good that he only has this
one
Knight he's he will get a new Knight
here oh it's my turn that's
good maybe a bishop
there
I should have taken a pawn
actually uh
no can you believe that I have no check
here time
warning I had absolutely no check
unbelievably
check yeah I
know I have to take yeah otherwise
something to G7 and
made here
back Knight H6 check can go
here can put something on G7 that's not
looking good
check
check yeah I have to take
check can I
somehow now one can take and that's it
in terms of checks and now I'm hitting
back with a
vengeance made only two
next that was crazy yeah it was crazy
house okay I will do a couple of normal
games and
uh so that we have some some normal
chess and probably let me check who's on
here yeah if I go for five minute will I
play OAS I won't he's not
[Laughter]
online okay so I'm going to do a couple
of normal chess games five
minute
oh wait I could do something else I can
do a couple of three minute just for a
change some three minute
um 3 minute it's not
so great in terms of commentary but game
started get some other opponents for a
change just for some normal chess
action I have to be quick
quick from the get-go
otherwise not so
great yeah this is an head
shock out from a queen's Indian type of
opening and I'm actually playing
quickly pre
moove yeah the
Hedgehog
yeah putting everything on the sixth
rank here
for a very solid
setup I don't know who don't know who
the white player is here SCT never
played him this is the benefit of once
in a while playing the three minute
games because you simply got different
opponents there are some guys who just
prefer to play three minute and they
don't play 5 minutes so it's something
something
different in terms of opposition yeah
I'm slightly worse here in this position
he's got more space and I cannot easily
get in D5 or
B5 Bishop f8 is just a little move
to consolidate I'm thinking about Rook
C7 here for Rook C8 and then possibly
B5 well
maybe
yeah I think Kenneth did a really good
job in the crazy house games my
experience there is limited but I think
he played well at least it looked like
that what what at least that what what I
what I could
see okay um what about D5 takes Knight
F6 Knight
F6
for Knight on D5 which would be quite
nice I
think I don't know it wasn't necessary
but I'm I had on the clock by a
mile wow this guy is terribly
slow or is he figuring out some
something brilliant now I don't
know this looks kind of normal yeah I
was thinking about
that
um take Knight
TS Jen he's not threatening very much I
think so I can play stuff like B5 yeah
normal moves let's
say uh rookie four maybe Rook E4 to G4
is a threat I should have thought about
that this one again Rook G4 is his
idea yeah H5 not very attractive
but I don't see a direct
reputation but Bishop f8 is covering all
the squares E7 G7 H6 D6 and so
on
[Music]
um Rook C2 here to get some pressure off
oops okay I can uh theoretically
speaking I could take now what about
this
actually where is he going now I can go
to C2
possibly as long as I'm not uh losing
directly this will be a time
win Rook
C2 also Bishop C5 in the
mix
check where do I
go White resigns he resigns because he
will lose on time but man of course I
can I can go here or here I'm just
winning material here was just much much
quicker um yeah I haven't played um I
haven't played uh um King Crusher for a
long while um it's simply we areall we
are different
um game we we are on on different times
so we are not getting paired often and
when we are we not play usually it's
just like we have played so many
games and um it's not that interesting
really I also sometimes cancel games
against my
teammates okay so the zish against the
Kings
Indian I shouldn't forget that this is
three minute chest very
important I have to play really quicker
than
usual yeah he's playing with with um C5
Boni style B6 is kind of a super fluous
move but
okay
okay F4 I want to kick him back the
knight from
H5 okay I have a nice Center and
possibly
E5 what seems harsh
okay E5 takes and D6 I could do that now
but I can also strengthen it a little
bit one idea is always yeah that I have
B4
now if he takes Knight takes B5 is is
excellent and this is a really nice Bon
now
Bishop to D4 I guess just keeping this
big control in the
center uh I have this
Square Bishop H6 is a not so great idea
I
guess okay let's let's just push a
head if this is good for black I'll eat
my head and I have
one that I could fetch from the room
next
door
um I I said if it is good for
black yeah not like I mean I can always
lose the game of course but I mean
really I just gave away F6 yeah and I
will take
that a piece is a piece is a piece also
in three minutes chess incoming res yeah
that was a
disaster
okay
um
[Music]
yeah yeah there is some discussion um
about playing against chess Network you
can yeah he's his name is Hypnotic
Spectre on the IC but U my games against
him don't have hypnotic Spectre in the
title because at the time I didn't
record
um I didn't record the opponent names
game start
tuang
2012 let's see what I can do here in
this three minute game I'm
actually winning some points here I
don't play that at all and uh my rating
is a little bit low with 2,200 in three
minutes
CH okay playing the kov variation of the
English that's a very nice line for
black I mean yeah very nice line it is
um it is um quite quite solid let's
say Okay um yeah he wants to take there
on
F6 C7 is
hanging huh not so nice Okay covering C7
um I will do um a
stream I will do a stream uh definitely
on chess Cube
sometime not quite sure when but I
will um and there will be the regular
streams
um
there will be the regular streams on
Monday and I will do streams beside that
but within
limits the hat that I could eat is um
some sort of yeah U Sun let's say um
head for the summer be basically to
protect you from the Sun so it's kind of
a tropical head yeah let's say we with
this kind of hairstyle you need some
protection against the
sun okay I'm going to try to get some
attack going here with F5 it's probably
not very solid
but what else is there that I can do
shuffling around won't help and here
this this guy is really I mean he's
taking all this time to trying to to do
something on the queen side maybe just
justifiably so
[Music]
but the chess stream is for IC is on
Mondays because IC asked me to do it on
a
[Music]
Monday so I'm doing it on a
Monday so what is this can I get some
attack here
Queen somewhere to H5 or something that
looks
um he wants to go B6 yeah I
know yeah B6 I'm playing without this
Rook yeah I saw that
but what what could I do
here
okay I he merry
Counterattack which is not going to work
let's see if he takes the
Rook he takes this there maybe I played
too much Buck house
here I was really thinking I could have
some attack but I have absolutely
nothing
yeah this is just material down for zip
for absolutely nothing time warning yeah
this is kind
of setting up for this but it's not
mattering very much
check now he has got Queen
E7
unfortunately or Knight h four or what
not they all win
[Music]
check Knight takes G6 is
checkm it was lost anyway but uh oo that
was bad
that was bad okay another another three
minute
game yeah videos in German
yeah once in a while maybe I was
thinking about
it
a new video in the modern classics
series H nothing planned at the moment
it is the the the modern um Classic
series is by far the series that takes
the most uh time to prepare and
produce it is not um not something to be
just done
quickly
not not easy at all those modern and you
had to find the games and they're
notoriously complicated absolutely
notoriously
complicated hard to figure out and if
you use uh let's say you put a let's say
you take a game from the early 2000s
sometimes you can uh you can just do it
like maybe E4 you can um oops maybe you
can um use some of the um comments uh
from the time but the problem is that
simply those comments often contains
tons of mistakes because they didn't
check with computers so much at the time
um so you have to do it all on your own
it's it's tough
work I have the question if I prefer
German or English yeah I mean um German
is a fine language but uh it's
uh nothing I mean there's nothing really
to prefer here or
there for some for some things um
English is
um is quite uh quite nice I
think it's
um there is some point to it yeah for
for for music sometimes it's uh often um
somewhat easier there in German but
there is some good German music of
course as well German language music I
mean the problem with the chess giant
Series this is less pronounced because
those older games they are less
complicated simply and uh there you
easily more easily you you have things
where things are more straightforward
and in the in those modern classic
series um it's not that
clear you have those tough complicated
battles all the time where you have a
hard time to understand what's actually
going
on yeah the king's Gambit was played
here and I have no idea what's happening
I think I have some good attacking
chances but he's got this funky Pawn on
F3 King f F7 maybe no it's going
there I I need to try to keep the king
in the middle Rook E1 and Rook H7
maybe yeah now he cannot cast long and
here I wanted to take and queen
H6 uh or queen H6 first but this F2 yeah
I have to I should take here
first maybe then go here also for queen
Queen
H5 ah my knight is not playing yeah
that's a big problem Rook E6 though yeah
looks kind of
strong it's good that I control
F1 yeah that looks
nice F6 is um pretty pretty much
indefensible um yeah Queen
takes time warning Queen takes I
guess he's somehow still hanging on
maybe here for F6 or is there something
stronger my knight does not play but
this is this is good
right
he cannot move the Knight as The Rook
hangs so I'm winning a piece
now
[Music]
check so threatening this check
here okay get some get some air for the
king some
Luft and controlling the F Pawn so this
is not that much of a
problem and I can play Bishop F5 next I
think Bishop
F5 not such a good idea maybe here yeah
for Rook to
D6 and if he moves the king I
mean I don't see a move
now check
yeah if he goes here and and I'm winning
winning the queen even so the king's
Gambit did
strike nice okay one more three minute
game Lo for the
king
okay I'm trying to get some more three
minute
in and they have also get a challenge
here can started accept this challenge
here for three minute
game Let's Play The King's Indian
okay now he wants to he's pinning me
that's not
nice
yeah this is a challenge this is a
different
rating this is a different
rating yeah this is this is a bit
annoying here this pin I have
to get rid of it right
away
I live in duborg this is North R West
failure not so far away from dorf or
cologne which you might
know yeah if you if you
saw this movie jungle Unchained yeah and
the the character that Crystal vultz is
playing um
Dr
what's his name he's from
dorf Schulz King Schulz he's from dorf
which is not far away from from where I
live and it was very funny I watched
this jungo and chain movie I watched it
in dorf and when when he was introducing
himself that he is yeah Dr King Schulz
from dorf people were laughing like
crazy this was fun really
fun I'm trying to trap his Bishop
here yeah his Bishop has no squares but
maybe um he has to play H4 here if I go
F6 now we can take
G6 I will just take this bishop
and try to win the PA
yeah yeah my name sounds polish um yeah
it's my the the site from my grandfather
is um coming from that area which at the
time was German in the early 20th
century and uh well nowadays this is
Polish so it's um check it's um in a way
polish in a way it's not
difficult so I don't have any relatives
there let's
say I mean at least not that I know
of okay so I will take the Rook or not I
guess I will take the
rook and now get get stuff out here Rook
[Music]
d8 H4 maybe
attacking if I will take if I take on G3
he might have Rook
H1 uh don't want to give him any counter
play
him
check I take on G3 that's some check ma
yeah to be
avoided got a
question why do Germans love David Hof
so
much uh yeah I don't know I I never was
a huge
fan
I don't know why other people liked uh
his his his song I I really have no idea
it was not me I didn't buy that
record this this stream is in English so
um time warning like my YouTube channel
is also in
English Okay I'm going to try to attack
here with a capture on D3 I can take
here now King F3 Queen E4 M check
incoming
challenge okay so I'm going
to accept another viewer challenge here
Pinchin this is an author right from
from
[Music]
Norway so I'm going to play the schan
yeah there was a request to play
[Music]
that let's see yeah the open f file is
something that is normally useful check
for
black
yeah the white play he took on C6 and
now will he be greedy taking on
E5 he takes on E5 I can take
[Music]
F2 I don't have many German videos on
YouTube it's um I have some some early
ones when I started the channel but then
I switched to English rather quickly
simply because the audience is um much
bigger I don't think that the modern is
better than the per P defense or perk
defense there are some obvious
transpositions but I don't think there
is a big difference in terms of
um in terms of
quality I Tred to get something here
with the queen on the king side an
interesting question is what happens if
he plays C4 but we don't have that I
tried to play the Knight to F4 now this
was why I went with Queen
E8 uh I can
take I don't like to thinking about
taking on F3 here yeah but maybe just
the pin is
[Music]
good okay I'll pile up here F double on
the
F5 this is really nice now for
black there was a question about the top
five chess Nations and
there was a quote here there was
something Russia China Ukraine Armenia
USA that sounds pretty
decent India will be also a force to
reckon
with they have many uh good Junior
players yeah China is already very
strong they won the chess
Olympiad okay I'm just putting
everything there is on the
King this is 3 + two by the way this is
the feeder Blitz time
control he's not really doing that much
here I can take
now I have this big Bishop on G6 I can
do this
now for Knight takes
G3 all pieces in their Tech is quite a
lot yeah if he takes Queen
[Music]
G3 check yeah the bishop here is a huge
force to reckon
with
this is probably a force
made
check the line Knight F3 F5 2d3 Knight
C6 D4 yeah it looks good for white yeah
I
guess
check okay so Rook F4 yeah for Rook H4
mate he can give one check on C4 but I'm
hiding and Rook H4 M will
come yeah the schan is um quite
strong I mean not like it uh it should
be game like this but it is quite strong
taking another challenge here from
Kenneth the guy who made a
22 draw tie against me earlier in um in
the crazy house so let's see what we can
do in normal chess it's what is this 3 +
2 as well so we have
some have some uh
[Music]
increment this is the ready let's see
what we get here you played a quick
Knight bd7 for E5
so I'm aiming for quick Central play if
he goes E4 I go Knight to
E5 Bishop D6 maybe that's not not bad
for for
black or not Bishop F4 I can play
maybe yeah we can go here threatening
Knight F7 so he probably has
to not sure this looks a bit tricky he
cannot cast now to Knight takes
F7 Knight C3 yeah I will put more
pressure on the
center yeah I will I will take this I
mean this is if I don't take this I'm
never going to win a
pawn
it's a question do you think you can
learn a lot by watching commentated
Blitz Games such as this um a lot hm I
think it is not uh not bad at all I mean
it is entertainment and you get the odd
the odd nugget of information but um
it's not like serious training but it is
it is the case it happens that there are
things that where you say oh that was
interesting and maybe something to to to
watch out for I mean I sometimes simply
instead of
watching some TV or so I'm just uh
watching some some some Blitz on YouTube
and once in a while I think oh that was
interesting that was maybe an
interesting opening or
whatever so it's not
um
yeah not a not a bad thing it I don't
think it can
hurt
F3 now that I think of it it looks a
little bit weakening but I am I'm in in
quick mode here this three plus two is
something
[Music]
different Knight E6 he's attacking D4
which is not so nice
maybe Knight A4 to C5 if he takes I've
got the the
total get the total Bishop pair if he
takes and on Knight E6 I have Rook
D1 covering the D4
Pawn so he wants to go Rook C4 here I
guess Bishop H3
though
uh I don't know Rook
[Music]
c43 Rook C4 yeah
indeed H maybe Queen
B3 I'm trying to offer for the queen
trade here Knight D4 I will take B6
first I don't know maybe Rook C4
here something like that the thing is
even if I lose a
pawn which can easily happen here I
still have the two
[Music]
Bishops yeah okay I'm giving up this
Pawn it's not a big deal this kind of
situation here is just fantastic for
white I've got two Bishops against two
knights and the better I mean the
Bishops are just
fantastic on B2 and G2 I'm threatening
to take on F6 now with the winning end
game I don't really know what he should
do to prevent it um yeah come on I'm
just taking
this
okay so Rook
D6 I can give some
checks it's not a big problem I
think H maybe I still should have done
something about it oh no this is not
going to work I can put in put this pin
on now which is essentially deadly will
win the piece or
and now I'm three point two pawns up in
the king and pawn end
game black
resigns
okay how do you know which pawns are big
deal and which aren't H yeah the the
thing here was if we go back I'm here
I'm a pawn up and I have two Bishops
against two knights in a wide open
position so what's left is just so
strong it's not mattering much that that
I'm um returning a pawn I mean I can
switch on the engine here and
I my I think the engine will be on
something like plus two despite equal
material 1.9 yeah
1.9 so it wasn't so far off let's see if
I get start another game here Busta
Buster from
Iceland let's
see yeah I will also do a rematch
against Kenneth but I was just bit bit
quick to to click on the three minute
button
um this guy is not playing not not much
I can do here just wait for the point to
roll in or maybe he's playing a
move
um yeah someone is recommending chess
tempo for tactics training yeah it's a
good side for tactic
puzzles yeah unfortunately I'm pretty
much I cannot do anything basically
while waiting uh for waiting for this
here to end this this sometimes happens
you and I mean I I will actually
normally I will offer an
abort because I don't want to to win
this kind of game but
um here at least it only takes three
minutes till the clock runs down it
happened to me also of course you
request such a game and you really then
you don't get one right away then
someone calls you or whatever have to go
to the bathroom and then all of a sudden
the game started and U you lose I don't
have a center hat
no yeah that's not much fun but I cannot
even do something
else
I mean like looking at some other game
or whatever it's just like I have to
[Music]
wait I have tried the end game trainer
on chess Tempo when I tried this is is a
t about two years ago it uh it was a
little bit tricky though because um they
in the in the endgame trainer they had
something in which was somewhat
connected to table bases and um it was
um it was tricky because sometimes you
you let's say I put in a move that wins
in 12 moves let's say and the best move
was winning in 10 so it said okay this
was a
mistake and I'm glad if I find a move
that wins in 12 and not in 10 so it's
not a big problem I'm a bit H coming
yeah this was uh bit
stupid I'm a bit skeptical about that
maybe it is uh better now that they have
improved
something um can you avoid the king's
Indian with one C4 not really I mean you
can of course avoid to play D4 after you
started one C4 but a king's Indian type
of setup black can play all the time
it's under
avoidable so Kenneth here is going for
the London system that is not very
exciting
but it can still lead to interesting
play in the long run let's
[Music]
see what's your what's my experience
with the rating difference between I
ts.com and so on uh I really don't care
u i mean they they are always a little
bit um there are always those
differences yeah some server is a little
bit higher some is a bit lower it
doesn't really
matter it doesn't really matter it's
just um a system I mean it is really not
mattering if if the if if chess.com
points are higher or lower it's just um
the the relation to one another you can
only say okay I'm like the number 10
Blitz player on chess.com or something
like that and um and these kind of these
kind of things but um you cannot compare
the the pure points in a way
so
yeah I got a a comment here
um there's no need for below 2,000
players to study the opening but how to
start a game without getting into
opening
disaster um I'm not sure that I said
exactly ly that but it is um I think the
problem is that players around 2000 they
start to do opening only and this is too
much you you should look a little bit at
the opening sure but it's not um that
important it really isn't you can play
the odd Sidelines yeah in some cases or
just avoid the extremely complicated
stuff where you have to learn for a long
time this is certainly possible
possible and um as long as you keep it
within reason it's also okay to study
the openings I mean I studied openings
all the time but it's not uh something
that you should do exclusively and this
is what some people do they start to get
uh get the the big opening books and
yeah those kind of grandm repertoire
stuff and try to learn this and it it it
eats enormous time and you're not doing
doing so much for your middle game when
you um learn lots of stuff by
heart okay so I'm I'm trading stuff here
what I'm hoping for is that long term I
can do something against those slightly
weakened pawns but it's nothing
brilliant that I have here I think about
equal
I would like to get my Bishop traded
maybe I can do this for Bishop A4 Bishop
C2 okay he's pushing forward but okay G5
I have Knight
H5 this is not really a threat F5 five
maybe I don't see a big threat so I try
to trade off my Bishop that was the idea
if the Knight moves and they probably
will I will go Bishop C2 okay he's
playing that but I thought Knight H5
now uh maybe he has Bishop E2
somehow now that's good for black I
believe unless I'm overlooking some
direct direct
tactical
stroke if I get this bishop straighted
there's also the Knight coming to F5 and
this will be yeah yeah this this here
this will be really really
annoying now Queen has to go to G4 and
now let's
[Music]
see I can just take D4
right
um how do you properly pronounce
sble yeah
sble it's um this is onion in
um in
English Okay uh how do I win this now
actually maybe taking here check Rook C1
check check and the bishop E4 okay he's
not doing
that maybe here
[Music]
yeah I've got a huge time
advantage
okay yeah I come on I just take this
this is this is
easy
check attacking F4 and attacking the the
Knight if I take with the Knight on F4
he has Queen E5
check which might might
be might be a perpetual so I rather take
with the
queen
check yeah he's still hanging on three
pawns
down let's go here Queen B1 for almost a
maid I guess so am
check
still attacking
here trying to hang
on what are you doing
check
check white resign yeah that's a night
end game with four extra pawns that's
that's quite a
lot Okay so what do we have here
incoming challenge this is a really long
stream
yeah this is really
long H maybe maybe one or two games like
three three minute a yeah I got a
challenge here game
started I got a challenge again so let's
see what's going on
here the TR
B oh Bishop
E7 not sure what's best again that
move okay here I've got pretty decent
development
so
certainly quite okay for for white that
should
be just developed normally this is the
kind of opening by the way there was a
question what opening to play when you
don't want to study lots of
theory and this is something that you
could do yeah the this kind of thing
yeah the trpovski
chowski or some Queen Pawn openings that
have some bi it yeah not the London
system in its uh in its dullest form
let's say but uh there are some some
possibilities
to to um get some life into the
game okay the the point here in this in
this position is that D5 is a weakness
that I can try
to to use with my my
knight I want to put the bishop on D5
though first
yeah his Bishop on F6 is relatively
um It's relatively
weak I haven't read any uh all
the all the comments where I
try yeah there is a discount code if you
uh want to join IC anyway then you can
use a code that you can enter while
joining
and the code is just ch explained for
10% they told me I would earn some
little money as well for every person
joining this uh with this uh bonus
account but I don't know what it
is
so this is a nice position yeah but how
do I continue it's not not so
easy it looks very
nice Knight to B7 I can play with B4 or
I can just trade with Knight C4 but this
doesn't look right yeah against this
piece on the edge of the board my Knight
here on on F3 should do something
decent but I don't know where
exactly yeah maybe just really regroup
ah this was bad now he has Bishop G5 ah
that was a that was a big positional
mistake
ah H that was
bad okay maybe I can go Bishop D2 Knight
takes a five this is maybe still
good you never want to trade one of your
Knights against this
bishop let's take it
[Music]
him
that that wasn't so great
right this bishop on G5 now is much
improved Knight D2 was
a silly was a silly
thing how do I continue here not
easy maybe B3 yeah solidifying
things
covering the Knight it's not so easy to
get anything going maybe Rook D3 F3 yeah
this is an idea
doubling where is he going Bishop to
F4 something like that I don't
know ah he's just
taking
interesting
I will take with the
pawn I don't want to trade more stuff my
Bishop is much stronger than his
Bishop his Bishop is never will never
attack anything and I have chances
against F7 G3 H4 Rook
F3 um
weird that the chess explain code
doesn't seem to be working they told me
it should work maybe try with uppercase
and so
on I obviously I couldn't test it
yeah yeah here I just have pressure on
F7 and I have chances to invade on the
a B6 hangs and I have this coming Rook
to
A7
yeah there's huge pressure here maybe
maybe not enough to win or anything but
it is very very
uncomfortable Queen A4 and then Rook A7
is the
[Music]
problem just preparing that he has
to basically play he's got a little bit
time left but other than that it's an
increment so is this how how good is it
actually it looks nice for white but how
do I
win H5 maybe
H5 would be nice to to get in something
like M on the h
f i take
here okay it's taking with the queen
time
warning I don't see a way really to win
this good
defense
check let's
enter it's still not much fun for black
somehow but I don't I don't see how I
could
win takes G3 Rook G3 keeps the pressure
on G4 maybe
G4 for Rook H3 Rook H5 this kind of
[Music]
thing okay if I go Rook H5
now he will play F3 so I have to do this
[Music]
first Rook
H5 okay Bishop E6 for Bishop Bishop
F5 this is this is a a nightmare for
black with seconds on the
clock check Queen H7
made black forfeits on time yeah it was
really really problematic yeah this kind
of position right here you're sort sort
of yeah this is a monster monster on D5
against the bishop on G7 I probably
didn't play it perfectly I mean well you
never play perfectly but I mean I I gave
him more than than than was necessary
probably but it was
always kind of difficult to
play around
here
just he defended this really
excellently check guess here maybe this
is objectively not so much but it it
gets it gets problematic now definitely
it starting here
H probably um probably
tricky check yeah it was nice very
difficult to hold this position very
difficult
oky dokie let's
check
so I'm going
for more three minute three minute
action and um I'm definitely not playing
a blindfold game at 1:30 in the morning
after two hours two and a half hours of
stream I will stop at the three hour
Mark um
yeah playing a little bit of an Italian
game just something
something nice and easy for a
change okay
okay yeah that's really not very
exciting next time I should do something
something else this is not very
exciting do I have an a little Edge at
least probably not I should have I
should have played Bishop G5 at least
would have been at
[Music]
least some idea okay well maybe I can
get an F for this is this is uh
possible wow he just he just ignores
everything here
okay
check
yeah there's not much going on I know
this is not very
exciting it wasn't a great idea to play
this opening this guy played this
well but okay you also have to play this
kind of
dull positions and try to win it
sometimes simply happens that you get
them
okay maybe I can get in
D4 it seems he wants to put the Knight
on G6 yeah
mhm maybe
not
okay let's open it
up let's open this up a little bit but
it's not easy to get anyway anywhere
anyway uh
anywhere maybe maybe I can create some
weaknesses
if oh
interesting okay let's let's try
something it's probably a little bit a
little bit risky
but otherwise oh and now I have check
coming and and Rook F4 this this should
be quite
good I
think maybe
not maybe not G3 yeah G3 might be a
tricky
business and he has Rook A1 all the time
H invisible chess invisible chess moves
is a really good book heavily
recommended I can take here
right the mate on
G7 okay I want a pawn check great have
to be very
very um modest
here one Pawn is a big deal from having
absolutely
nothing The sorcerous Apprentice by
David David
bronstein um this is supposed to be um
this is supposed to be a really good
book and it's one of the few um classic
books let's say um oh I only have 24
seconds I'm playing this here this is
one of the few classic books that I
don't
know I always wanted to get it but I I
keep forgetting it that I want to get
[Music]
it 21 seconds that's not
good
I I just have to be quick
here like no tomorrow
[Music]
check King F5 G6 is the the way to try
to win
this I really
slow n should have taken E4
immediately draw
offered draw yeah this is useless I mean
from the two points down here for for
nothing after really I completely I
completely lost track
here invisible chess moves um is an
interesting uh book it's a basically a
collection of positions and
um um a collection of positions where
people made mistakes and it's
interesting um to see how the mistakes
are related to some motives like some
things are are very difficult or are
very common let's say mistakes yeah like
you tend to overlook Knight moves back
to the the first rank or the eighth rank
or queen moves back these kind of things
it's uh very
interesting um my YouTube channel is my
first experience in broadcasting yes
never did anything like that
before move first think later is a very
interesting book
by um Dutch I am vly Hendrick
interesting started interesting read I
definitely won't play the Italian game
again this is the blue shark 23 tbbor
tonai this is an old oldtime
GM um the dorety and user books there's
a question about them it depends on the
books the dorety books are basically all
for strong players and some of them are
for a high for a level that is basically
unclear to me me uh simply because the
exercises are so difficult that even
really really really strong players fail
to to get
anywhere uh I mean like Grand Masters
yes and um therefore I have my doubts
about the value of those books they can
be uh they can be uh good for really
strong players but normal guys I don't
know um user PFF however has this is a
mixed bag he's uh made this uh this
series boost your chess excelling your
chess build up your chess and um this um
is something uh that I really like this
series is um is um something that I use
very much in my own in my own uh uh
coaching I he has very good examples in
the book and U if you for example um are
somewhat lower rated like let's say
1,400 1300 then those books the the
first ones they are really really okay
they will help you quite uh quite a lot
I think and this is a build building up
from really low level to higher level so
it's um Che something that um you can
start small with and then build up from
there so it's a good series of books
yeah we have um an interesting position
here an endgame position this guy simply
traded down everything hoping that his
Bishop PA is um doing something uh I
understand the point but still his
Bishops are not that active at the
moment so I don't believe it is a a big
deal and this guy he's a supreme
tactician
but I rather play this kind of dry end
game against him than then some some
weird tactics even if he's got the
bishop
here I think
um it doesn't matter that much and I'm a
huge Bishop per addict of course as you
probably know from my channel
so yeah I got a question about pump up
your rating which is uh I think pretty
good
what I saw it makes a a good
impression my Bishop here is not a good
piece h i wonder maybe this is still a
problem for
me how do I coordinate this bishop to D4
maybe oh I forgot about that move
completely War earlier I could easily
easily react to it with Knight D4 but
not
now and I cannot go D4 H that's not
great that's not a move I like to
play H
okay difficult to coordinate this
very yeah I miss I misplaced that
misplayed that
terribly really
[Music]
w a really bad
position
check
oh I never looked at that
[Music]
move I he got Bishop F3 even now
I completely misplayed that end game it
was pretty good at the start but I
screwed this up totally Wow Come
On In
challenge I really let me let me check
here
something this and I mean I think this
is just this end game should be totally
okay for wi check I was actually
thinking why is better here due to the
space what did I do there what what made
what what what did I do
wrong
this I must have done something wrong
this cannot be worse for white ever yeah
absolutely not but what is what is the
problem Bishop e seven I have to go of
course I have to start with this I have
to kill his his Bishop here yeah then
I'm okay I can never be worse here yeah
this is a problem okay okay
okay
okay so um what do we have okay like two
or three more
games
how to study middle game yeah middle
Game Study is something where um G lots
of lots of people struggle with struggle
with whoop talking too much
um one good thing is that um you can one
good idea is for Middle Game Study you
look at your openings what you play the
kind of structures that you get yeah
like here let's say you play the cilian
then you pick cecilian games and look
through them and think um okay how how
exactly is the cilian played what other
the ideas look for games by strong
players that uh are are experts in the
opening and it's not about learning
moves by heart it's
about trying to figure out how they play
the opening what is what are the
ideas where do the pieces belong and
that will help you to develop better
feel for what's going on so that you
find the the um the good moves over the
board the books by aard are all really
good
yes okay this guy here is sacrificing on
E6 which is a pretty normal thing to
happen in this opening but exactly here
I don't
know I mean I I have castled even so it
gives me pretty strong
pieces I
think there's a there's a question what
player um should you study if you have a
feeder let's say 1650 is player um to be
honest there's no clear recommendation
um many many things that you could study
the the I think the most important thing
is is that you enjoy what you're
studying so if you like a certain um
player just study what this player is
doing I don't think there's a big theory
on tactics you can just do it um you
just it's it's like running yeah there's
no big theory on running well let's
let's say you just have to do it all the
time and get get quicker and quicker
it's like building up stamina
tactics okay um am I not just crashing
through here on F2 this is irritating
me like here and I will take on
F2 check let's just take
that and turn I F6 back or is there
something
better my knight on H5 is hanging that's
not so great okay let's just go
back
um I don't know Pawn structure chest by
saltis
there's a there is a question can you um
still achieve I am or feedom Master
title if you start at
18 um yeah you certainly can but I'm not
sure if really everybody can yeah I mean
you have to have a certain degree of T
talent for the game I'm pretty sure it's
not just all about time
having enough time is uh is certainly I
mean yeah you need to have uh some time
invested but um it's also necessary to
have some natural talent for the game
there might be people who simply cannot
do
it Knight E4 is a possibility
here oh wait this is actually a funny
tactic right time
warning I see a funny tactic
Knight F2 Knight F2
check check and then Knight H3 and I'm
I'm a piece up at the end this is quite
nice nice tactic crazy house sometimes
you see brilliant tactics if you play
Crazy house but you can blunder a knight
in one
move ah
this King
F7
great great just
great how idiotic can you be king to
F7 unbelievable stuff at least I'm still
better yeah now I'm
winning why did he allow the the trade
[Music]
there
oh I have Auto promotion off I have to
switch that back on
check incom challenge let me I have to
do auto promotion off on on
again okay
what do we have I do I play one one
final
game one one final game I have to really
wrap it
up it's really
late yeah and Blitz you often see more
in kibing than when you play yourself
that's really a very common thing to
happen
yeah not so easy to get a crazy house
game I
think I'll just I have a look but
nothing what is my favorite euro vision
song I don't know is there anything
good um
zov's winning chess middle games is a
good book yep it's a good
book I didn't have a coach no yeah this
is Martin suanda that I'm playing German
I
am it's about about my my rating
level and we have a chenko slav where
white is um playing on the queen side I
have I have to admit that I forgot this
I forgot how this is exactly
played for A3 I I
think I thought that this was bad for
black but maybe I'm
wrong huh Maybe I'm Wrong
here
[Music]
yeah
try yeah I will take here clarify
matters
not sure how good it is but it shouldn't
be bad
here can take take here on A1 Queen A1 I
mean I'm better developed and I have
some ideas like Queen A8 after the
trade Queen A8 is slightly
problematic his Queen yeah looks active
but it can also be a
liability the C6 Pawn is also very
week Queen A5 is an interesting move now
not not the only move
certainly Bishop A6 is also just strong
yeah come on this is simple and good I
believe oh wait he can he can actually
just
Castle
it's it's good in many ways actually
Bishop
A6 a shame that this is this is three
minute Queen A7 is also good I really
don't know what to do it's all
good it's all good for White Queen A7 KN
Queen A5 everything's
good
[Music]
I have answered political questions
before but with one minute on the clock
in a non increment game It's
Tricky my idea is now Bishop A6 or
Knight
A5 this was bit of a routine move now
maybe there was something
better Bishop A6
yeah there's a there's a request to
kibit
Nakamura he's not even
on the problem is that here the the the
pawn on C6 is super
vulnerable he has no way to defend it
really and there's Queen C8
coming yeah I can just take C6 now and I
will if he castles I'll take D7 it is a
total win for
white yeah this is basically the way um
the idea of this this specific opening
line for white time warning um what is
this idea I can give the check here
right check I don't see a counter playay
Rook E1 coming and D7 is always hanging
so if he castles I just take the
Knight yeah that's that's that's really
over so um Rook
E6 check well this this this should be
enough
two pawns right in the
center and a
knight that is enough even at two in the
morning res
challeng okie dokie guys this is two 2
in the
morning I have to stop
this I have to stop this really I have
to go to bed I have to actually um
believe me or not I have to get up in
about 4 hours and uh do some things not
not working on chess but uh some other
private obligations I have to go to bed
now sleep like 4 hours and then have to
be back again okay I hope you enjoyed it
this was a really long stream a really
long stream some crazy house from 3
minute chess I hope it was good
entertainment thanks for watching this
for those who really were on like 3
hours you made it tough guys okay well
thanks for this and I'm off for tonight
bye-bye